so many paradoxes which tell you that
this picture nice picture of four
dimensions and all events being there is
far from being the truth let me just
give one example and then then I'll
finish a single Photon hits a a half
silvered mirror you have two detectors
here I made some money with this one of
them is going to give you a click and
the other is not going to give you a
click nothing nothing nothing in physics
can tell you so here are two events two
possible events in the future which
nothing in the present can tell you
which of them will occur that tells you
that the future in some very profound
way does not
exist